detailed and intriguing images of
cityscapes from around the world have
made Steven world trip famous
internationally a selection of his work
is on sale at his London gallery a
drawing by Stephen Wiltshire can cost
anything between one thousand seven
hundred and two hundred thousand euros
I'm really satisfied for my work because
I would like to and I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it my way Stephen Wiltshire is
a born and bred Londoner and the city is
a constant source of inspiration to him
he sometimes takes photos of views that
speak to him but he draws and paints
from memory
it's so beautiful up there with Shaka
cd-r the London Eye and I see them half
of our county hall and Hungerford
footbridge and bit of a give evil role
Festival Hall back in his studio with
the views still fresh in his mind
Stephen will to begins drawing West
Minister bridge the love doing work I'm
gonna memorize it because it gives me a
hard work and we love my job sometimes
dozens quick sketch of it and much for
very natural but not just going to be
detail this time it's cuz very bit of a
quickie sketch a quickie sketch that is
astonishingly detailed a true-to-life
snapshot of the world as the artist sees
it I think of the important stuff
important stuff is mean since that means
that the concentrations and them and
realized and to memorize them by my mind
Stephen Wiltshire was diagnosed with
autism when he was three he began
drawing when he was five his talent was
immediately obvious he when a series of
art competitions went on to graduate
from art school and is now a celebrated
artist and draftsman with an
international reputation
I think I might get better doing your
drawing if I like it to do to do it must
doing the best and I'll never stop
Stephen Wiltshire often takes helicopter
trips over cities storing what he sees
in his memory and later recreating the
view in the form of gigantic panoramas
here in Mexico City he spent several
days on a panorama of the city working
in full view of the public
around 100,000 people came to watch
meanwhile his worked all over the world
like her New Yorkers my best my best
place and a lot about many times so
about eight times I think and I've been
to Dubai Singapore Hong Kong and I've
been to UM Tokyo and some plating lots
of places in and do some panoramas this
summer Stephen Wiltshire will be
visiting Los Angeles one more city to
cross off his list
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]